>>Alex Danilo: Hello, everybody.
And welcome here tonight.
You have waited for the keynote act, I see.
We're the last act of the day, best of the
day, of course.
So I guess you're all wondering why Adobe
is here.
The answer to that is they're a very valued
contributor to the WebKit project, and WebKit
project is of course the core of Google Chrome
and a lot of other nice browsers out there.
And of course, we like to share because of
course the Web is about sharing.
And what I mean is I don't mean social media.
I mean they're a bunch of mad scientists -- actually,
visionary physicists back in the early '90's
-- and they decided they wanted to share physics
stuff, like scientific papers, so they built
the first Web browser and Web server.
And then a few years later Marc Andreesen
came along and said, Well, images would be
cool and he added images to the browser.
And then over the years, as you've seen, the
evolution of the Web has just gotten better
and better and we have all these amazing features
today.
So basically the Web is open and so Adobe
and Google we all work on Web technology,
we work with a lot of other companies as well.
So enough about that.
Who are we?
My name is Alex Danilo, and I'm a developer
advocate on Chrome.
And with me I have Christian Cantrell, who
is a product manager, a developer himself,
so he knows a lot of the stuff that you guys
do.
And we also have Vincent Hardy, who is a principal
scientist.
And Vincent and I have worked on CSS and SVG
for a number of years now.
So the Web is evolving and that's a really
good thing because we don't really want the
browser from the early '90's, do we?
And the thing is what we're seeing now is
along the timeline of Web browser evolution
all these new features have been coming in
and coming in and the feature set is accelerating.
New features are not just accelerating, but
there an accelerating acceleration.
So the thing is what do you do as a developer?
It's like we want to help you.
And that's why we built Chrome.
Chrome is built for simplicity, security and
speed.
And what's going to give you simplicity is
tools.
It better tools to make your job easier and
that will give you more time because it will
make your development job faster, so we give
you simplicity and speed, and that's what
we're going to show you today.
Now, what are you supposed to do as a Web
developer?
Come to Google I/O. And the second thing is
go watch all the YouTube stuff, go watch it
afterwards, enjoy it, get all the demo material,
experiment with it.
And one thing I would really like everyone
in this room and everyone watching to do is
to talk to us.
The Web is about people, it's open, we share,
and we listen to you.
So if you as a Web developer sit around and
you go like, "Oh, I wish CSS did that," come
and tell us, we'll try and push it through
the standards bodies, we'll get the other
browser makers to do it and we'll do it together.
So anyway, this is the kind of thing we're
trying to promote today, more creative options.
The old days used to muck up a wire frame,
give it to the Web developer who writes JavaScript
and something pops out the other side.
And we want to change that workflow.
We want to, like, bring on the declarative
Renaissance.
So we're putting features in the browser that
are declarative.
They're not JavaScript.
And we're providing tools so the designers
can come along and go, Well, I can build that
page myself.
I don't need to give it to a JavaScript programmer.
And so Adobe, of course, had a rich history
in topography and fonts and graphics, so the
stuff we'll see today is a whole lot of new
CSS features, from magazine style layouts,
some cinematic effects and amazing graphic
type stuff, and of course we bring this all
to you in Chrome.
And if you're sitting there going, "Oh my
God, my users use IE, a really old version,
what do we do about that," well, we give you
Chrome Frame as well so you can have Chrome
and Chrome Frame and they provide the platform
on which you can make these incredible new
apps.
The other thing is we bring tools, we have
Chrome Developer Tools, and of course Adobe
we're about to show you some new tools they
have been working on.
And of course with their tools and our tools
it creates a synergy that makes your workflow
so much easier and smoother.
And of course, the one thing that I'll emphasize
yet one more time is that the Web is open,
the Web is everybody's, and we both participate
in the W3C and a number of other standards
organizations.
In fact, there are over 370 companies who
are participating in the W3C and they steer
the direction of the Web.
So if you want a new feature, come to us,
we'll do it for you, okay?
So on that note I'll pass it over to Christian
and he shall tell you all about these features.
>>Christian Cantrell: Thank you, Alex.
So I think probably the best way to understand
the perspective of Adobe when it comes to
helping to move the Web forward is to look
at the Web platform team's official "Le Motto,"
which is a better Web and awesome tools.
So I'm going to be talking about three things
that are going to help us achieve that goal,
the first of which is text.
So the Web is already a very powerful platform
for text, so Adobe wanted to build on that
because we really wanted to bring magazine-like
layout to the Web.
And we want to do that -- we're doing that
in primarily two ways with two specifications
and two implementations as well, CSS Regions
and CSS Exclusions.
The example you see here is using CSS Exclusions
to have some text flow along the edge of this
mountain.
Here's another example where you see text
flowing between different regions, in this
case to make columns, also flowing along these
images here.
So this is combining CSS Regions and CSS Exclusions.
Now, this is the kind of thing that you're
probably accustomed to seeing, we're all accustomed
to seeing really in print and magazines or
something like that.
Usually not something that you would see on
Web.
Something like this the Web would typically
have been laid out in another application,
a screen shot would have been taken or something
strange like that, which obviously we don't
want.
We really want true magazine-like layout with
the Web.
So I'm going to start with the CSS Regions,
and this is just sort of a brief overview.
The concept of CSS Regions is actually quite
simple.
You have a block of text here, a flow, you
have some elements here which are your regions,
and with a couple of lines of very simple
declarative CSS, that text can start flowing
through those regions.
It's that simple.
I'm going to actually start with a couple
of demos to help illustrate the point.
In addition to being a developer at Adobe
I'm also a science fiction writer.
And I frequently write things and release
them under a creative comments license online.
And when I release them they tend to look
something like this, which is to say ugly,
right?
So I put a lot of work into the story and
then I release it in a way that I'm not really
that proud of.
And the reason is because I want it to work
on as many devices as possible.
I know people like to read on phones, they
like to read on tablets, they like to use
all kinds of different types of browsers and
machines, so I try and make it sort of the
lowest common denominator.
But it honestly doesn't look that good, so
when I started working with CSS Regions I
was really excited about what I could do with
my own work and how I could present it in
a much more interesting fashion.
So this is the same story which I've applied
some regions to.
And you can see that I have a page count up
here, which is nice, and you can see that
my text is flowing from region to region here
all automatically.
I have some page numbers down here.
If I were to resize my browser here you can
see the page count in the upper right-hand
corner is changing.
As the page count changes, if I drag it up
and decrease the height of the available space
you can see the pages have automatically adjusted
themselves.
So this is a much nicer experience and something
that I can be a little bit more proud of.
I have a couple more prototypes, but I want
to go ahead and skip to the last one, which
is my favorite.
I call this the sort of adaptive or responsive
prototype.
And this is unique because it's designed not
just to work on any size screen, it's designed
to actually be optimized for any size screen.
So this is the same story once again, but
it uses -- it has some gestures where you
can turn pages.
It uses some heuristics to determine the optimal
width for a column and the optimal -- the
maximum number of columns it can fit.
And you can see if you have much higher resolution,
it will automatically determine your column
width for you and add more columns.
Even the graphic here on the left-hand side
is scales as I change the column width because
it's done with SVG.
So this thing -- this layout is going to work
on a screen as big as a wall or something
as small as just a phone.
So I had a lot of fun working with my own
content with this.
And I started thinking that I really wanted
to be able to consume other content on the
Web in a really nice way as well.
And you know, I really wanted to be able to
just sort of reflow content into sort of a
magazine or book-like format really easily,
so I started experimenting with this Chrome
extension that I call Qualify.
And when I click on this extension up here
all the content on the page is just automatically
reflowed using CSS Regions in a way that I
think is much nicer to consume, and it's all
adjustable based on font size and all that.
As an aside, if you guys went to any of these
shadow DOM sessions or Web component sessions,
this is actually using the shadow DOM, so
it's not polluting the DOM at all.
So as far as the DOM is concerned, you know,
if there are scripts running on the DOM or
something, actually nothing has changed here
at all.
It's all done behind the scenes on the shadow
DOM.
If you have no idea what I'm talking about,
shadow DOM is awesome.
Check it out.
Okay.
So since we're making contributions directly
to WebKit, any browser that leverages WebKit
is going to receive the benefits of those
contributions.
And in this case the Chrome beta -- actually,
I shouldn't say beta anymore, it's not in
beta anymore since like yesterday, I guess.
So Chrome on Android also has some CSS Regions
support, so this is the screen shot I took
from my Galaxy Nexus.
So let's look at some code.
The first thing I want to point out here is
just a simple selector called content.
And it has a property called flow-into here.
And this flow-into property is creating a
named flow called article.
And what's notable about this is that my content
is just going to be a big block of semantic
text.
So I'm not worried about, you know, creating
divs or some form of element that are regions
and copying and pasting text into each one.
Obviously that would defeat the whole purpose.
That's not really flowing.
You could have done that forever.
So you have this semantic block of text which
is content and it knows nothing about the
way it's going to be laid out.
And then I have this class called region.
And it has a flow-from property here, and
it's referring to this named flow article,
which is defined up here.
So with just that I'm able to get text flowing
between regions.
Now, what about getting paging capabilities
and, you know, the swiping effects and the
columns and the layout and all that?
In order to do that you will have to write
some code.
You're going to have to tap into the CSS object
model.
And it's not a lot of code.
It actually pretty straight forward, and I'll
just go through it.
We started our layout with a function called
add region here, and I created a new region.
And I'm going to set this attribute, the class
attribute, to region, which we saw in the
previous slide is the named flow.
And this is a really important line of code
right here, this region.addeventlistener.
So we're gonna add this region.addeventlistener
to our region, and we're going to call this
function called on layout update.
Basically what this is saying is if the text
inside that region changes in any way, if
text is added, if text is removed, if the
font size changes, if the element is resized
for any reason, then call this on layout update
function so that I can run some -- you know,
take a look at the page, figure out what happened
and update my layout.
And then just add that region to the -- pin
that region to the body of the document.
So let's look at this on layout update function.
Again, this is called whenever my flow changes
within my regions, so I get a reference to
the region from the event target, nice and
straightforward, and then I start looking
at this region overflow property.
And if the value of that property is overflow,
which is to say if there's more text than
actually fits in that region, then I'm going
to need to add another region.
So I sort of recursively call this add region
function, right?
Otherwise if it fits, then call region layout
complete and you're done, you can do your
layout and stuff.
So what's missing from this is the code that
determines the width of your regions, the
placement of your regions, the left, right,
top, bottom, and all of those kinds of things.
It puts page numbers and the scrolling effects
and all that, but that stuff's actually not
all that bad.
And the very first prototype that I wrote,
I wrote that in, you know, a day.
The last one, you know, I sort of built a
few prototypes, takes a couple of days.
And these are the kinds of things that people
will write, they'll open source.
I'll open source everything I've done here
along with a qualified plug-in so people can
see how it's done.
So it's not bad to do all this stuff yourself,
but we know that it has to be easier.
We know that people want to do it in a declarative
way.
And so we've proposed something called CSS
page templates.
And CSS page templates really come from our
experience with tools like InDesign, which
is what you're looking at here.
This is a screen shot of InDesign where I've
created some master pages.
One master page has an image in the upper
left-hand corner, another master page has
an image in the center here with two columns
of text on either side.
And what I can do is I can just add pages
to my document and just apply these master
pages to those pages and they're automatically
formatted the way I want them.
So it's really nice and easy.
We've learned from building these kinds of
tools that, you know, people want easy ways
of doing these kinds of things.
So let's take a look at CSS page templates.
We're going to look at it in two parts.
The first one is the flow.
And this is probably pretty familiar because
this is more or less what we just looked at,
except for instead of creating one named flow,
I'm creating two.
So I have a selector called article and a
selector called timeline and I'm creating
two named flows here, the article flow and
the timeline flow.
And then I have this selector here, combine
articles.
And it has this interesting property called
overflow style.
And I'm saying page X.
So this line of code is basically saying "Don't
call my -- don't call my event handler and
make me have to add regions and lay them out
and all that, just page X, page along the
X axis," in other words, page horizontally.
So the templates themselves, you use this
@ syntax to define them.
So we have an outer definition of a template
here and then we have slots inside of the
template.
In this case we have a left template and a
right template.
Both of these are getting their content from
this article flow.
Then we have a center slot which is getting
its content from the timeline flow.
So pretty straightforward, simple, declarative
stuff, CSS that everyone is comfortable with,
and the result is something like this.
We have some English text here which is flowing
from left column to the right column, and
then we have this German text which constitutes
a timeline which is flowing along the center
column.
And it's paging along the X axis as we specified,
or in other words paging horizontally.
There are seven pages total.
And all of that was just with a few lines
of declarative CSS.
Now, this is still a proposal; however, we
do have shims or polyfills, JavaScript polyfills
or shims, that you can use to actually see
this stuff in action and actually see it work.
And we'll have a URL on that at the end of
the presentation.
It's not enough, though, just to be able to
flow text from region to region.
If you really want true magazine-like layout
you need more powerful tools than that, or
I should say additional tools.
And this is a screen shot of InDesign.
This is where somebody has flowed some text
around a clipping path here.
Right?
Again, that's something we're used to seeing
in print.
We want this on the Web.
This is an example of it happening on the
Web.
Again, this is both CSS Regions, where text
is flowing between regions, and also the exclusions
where text is flowing along the contours of
this image.
So where are we with CSS Exclusions right
now?
We're really focused on some of the low level
implementations which really involve the optimization
of algorithms that flow text around polygons
and inside of polygons.
I'll actually show you a quick demo here.
This is something that one of our engineers
put together.
And you can see that this is just sort of
an example of an algorithm that determines
on the left side how a text should flow inside
of some arbitrary polygon.
In this case it's a star shape.
And on the left it's content flowing around
the polygon.
And so this is stuff that has to be really
bulletproof and has to be really performing.
So right now we're really focusing on optimizing
those algorithms.
They're going to be contributing directly
to the WebKit, and that's going to be the
foundation on top of which we build Exclusions.
Okay.
So this is a really busy slide.
I'm not going to go over this.
This would bore you guys all to death.
It's too late in the day for that, but I wanted
to just point out one really important element
of this timeline.
This is basically the full timeline of everything
from when we first started thinking about
Regions and Exclusions all the way up through
the present.
I really want to focus on this bottom row
here, the blue row.
I was at Google I/O last year and I was working
at the booth and I was demoing CSS Exclusions
and Regions, and people would come up and
take a look at it -- and we had a prototype
back then.
It was just a prototype build.
And they'd look at it and they immediately
got it, right?
When you see text flowing around shapes and
everything it's awesome.
And so they would say, Wait, what browser
is that?
Are you using Firefox?
Is that WebKit?
Is that Chrome?
Is that Safari?
Like what is that?
And I would say, Well, this is actually our
own prototype browser.
This actually doesn't work anywhere.
And they'd like walk away kind of crest fallen
and be like "Damn, I kind of wanted to do
that."
So a year later, almost exactly a year later,
all of the live demos that I showed you work
in the version of Chrome that all of you have
on your computers right now, which is really
remarkable to me.
That's one year's time.
80 percent of CSS Regions has implemented
and is in Chrome and is on your computer right
now.
So we're making really good progress.
As far as other browsers, Mozilla has committed
to Exclusions and Regions in their 2012 road
map.
The preview version of IE 10 supports Regions
and Exclusions.
And since the implementation is being done
directly in WebKit, we expect the next major
version of Safari to pick it up as well.
I'm going to change gears a little bit here
and I'm going to talk about the Web development
workflow, something a little different.
Actually, instead of talking about it, I think
I'll do a little demonstration.
So I'm going to open up my text editor here
and I'm going to open up a little prototype
website that I am going to pretend like I'm
working on.
And I'm going to talk about the Web development
workflow, which typically looks something
like this.
You start off in your editor.
You make some kind of a change.
Maybe you wonder if this menu belongs at the
top or not.
So you remove it, you save it, you alt tab
over to your browser and you hit command R
to reload.
You say nah, I really wanted that.
You go back, you undo, you save, you go back,
you reload.
And if you're a Web developer, which I'm assuming
that all of you have at least some Web development
experience, if not many years of experience,
you do this thousands of times a day, right?
It's completely ingrained in muscle memory,
and it's a pretty good workflow, right?
There's no compilation process or anything
like that.
It's pretty fast, pretty smooth.
Maybe you use something like live reload,
which makes it even slicker.
Now what happens when you add mobile into
that workflow, as we increasingly are.
If you are building a website now, you are
probably thinking about mobile to some degree.
Well, you still have this workflow that I
just described, but you have this entire additional
workflow that's like -- pulls it down and
-- and really makes it much less efficient,
right?
So it looks a little something like this,
You go through that process I just described,
you go okay let me check on my device.
So up pick up your device, and it's been a
while so it's locked.
So you unlock it.
And you are security conscious, because you
are a at Google conference so you have to
enter your PIN, of course, then you have to
navigate to your browser, then you have to
type in this URL, this long complex URL of
your development machine or whatever it is
and you make at least one or two mistakes,
of course.
Then you fix 'em and you check it out.
Then when you are done with that, then you
can just pick it up and hit reload, but you're
still picking it up, unlocking it hitting
reload.
Picking up the next device,unlocking, hitting
And on the very last one, you're going to
find a bug, right?
And then you're going to go back to your desktop
and fix it and you're going to start all over
again.
So the really cool process that we're all
pretty very much accustomed to becomes really
pretty terrible on mobile devices when you
incorporate mobile devices into this Web development
workflow, but I guess I shouldn't say terrible.
But it's not as efficient, let's put it that
way.
So Adobe looked at that problem and thought
that maybe we could do something about it.
So I'm going to switch over to -- to my browser
here.
And assuming that I have an internet connection,
if I'm lucky, I'm going to go to the Boston
Globe.
I'm lucky.
And the reason that I'm picking the Boston
Globe here is because this is sort of a famously
responsive website which probably required
thousands and thousands of combined hours
of testing on mobile devices so that people
who built this, very smart people, and they
know the pain.
Now, what I'm going to do is I'm going to
come over here and switch over to the ELMO.
And I'm going to put my devices over here
on the left and I'm going to put my -- my
left anyways -- and I'm going to put my desktop
over here on this screen.
And what you are going to see is that they're
all synchronized, right?
And I'm going to click on an article here,
and they all follow along, right?
So that same Web development workflow that
I showed you earlier, now I can -- I can still
do with all of my devices connected, right?
I can just glance over and see.
I don't have to pick them up, I don't have
to change URLs, I don't have to tap on links
and all that kind of thing.
There's no limit to the number of devices
that you can connect to here, by the way.
Something else I want to point out here is
Adobe shadow, it's not like bundling up this
content and pushing it out to the devices,
right?
Rather it's telling the devices to go make
its own request for the content.
And that's an important distinction because
that means that the user agent and the http
headers and all of the information that the
server needs in order to determine the correct
content to send to that particular device
is all present.
So you can get, you know, smaller images if
you are on smaller screen or higher resolution
images if you are on one of these nice new
modern screens or whatever it is, right?
So you are seeing the real deal on these devices.
So let's see here ... it's nice to be able
to, you know, just this much is sort of a
big win, but there's even more we can do.
If I click on the little shadow extension
up here in my browser, I can do some remote
inspection of my device here.
And so I've now connected to my iPad and you
can see that as I start to mouse over the
content, in my Web Inspector on my desktop,
you can see this being highlighted on my iPad
over there.
So this is, you know, the kind of thing that
we're accustomed to doing, you know, on our
-- when we're doing Web development on our
desktop and now it extends nicely to our devices.
And we can do more than just highlight, we
can also change things so I can, you know,
say something like -- I can change this headline
to be a little more relevant to me, right?
So I just changed the headline over here.
I prefer something like this.
I can execute some JavaScript remotely on
any one of these devices.
See I just popped up an alert here.
So I will come over here and dismiss it.
So after I've sufficiently messed up this
page by vandalizing it or whatever, I can
just come over here, pull it down and refresh
it.
If you guys have done development on a lot
of different mobile devices, you will know
that clearing the cache is actually kind of
a pain, like getting a fresh copy of everything
on all of these different devices, and so
shadow takes care of that for you by dumping
the cache and making a fresh request.
Or if I want to do it to all of my devices,
I will just come over here and I will tell
them all to refresh, so I will click on that.
I don't know if you saw, but they all just
refreshed, it's very quick.
Also I can take screen shots of all of my
devices here.
I'll just click on this icon, takes a little
bit of time, open up the directory here and
you can see that I have -- this is the screen
shot from my iPad, so I can compare them all,
sort of check out pixels next to each other.
[ Applause ]
>>Christian Cantrell: Oh, thank you.
Awesome.
That is worthy of applause, I agree, thank
you.
This is the Galaxy Nexus here, and also some
text files were created with some meta data
so I can, you know, sort of get a good feel
for how something looked for the specific,
you know, URL and LS version and stuff like
that.
So -- so there's shadow.
It's available right now.
You can go to labs.adobe.com, download it,
see if it helps for your workflow.
I'm a big fan myself.
Okay.
I'm going to change gears again and talk a
little bit about tooling.
So tooling is something that Adobe is well
known for.
We do a lot of tooling, so when we were looking
at ways we can contribute to the Web, tooling
was something that seemed kind of obvious.
But we didn't just want to go create sort
of the same old kinds of tools.
We really wanted to take a fresh approach
and see what kind of innovation we could bring
to tooling.
So we decided to experiment with an open source
code editor for the Web written entirely with
Web technologies.
Just to see what would happen.
And what happened was something called brackets.
I'm going to go through a few bullet points
here and then I'll get to the demo, but I
want to provide context here.
First of all, it's open source.
When I say it's open source, I mean it's open
source, right?
Like a lot of companies, they used to say
something was open source and we'd all go
oh cool it's open source, and you would look
at the license and be like wait a minute.
Open source is actually kind of a useless
term.
So really what license?
And we are releasing under MIT license, and
that's a very, very liberal license.
All of the codes on GitHub, even the backlog
is public.
It's on a site called Trello, so you can actually
go see what the team is working on.
So everything is being done in the public.
There's also IRC channels and there's lists
and stuff like that that you can follow.
This is something that we realized kind of
early on, which is kind of cool, this concept
if you can use brackets, you can hack on brackets.
If you need brackets, if you use brackets,
you can change brackets.
This point was really driven home to me when
I was working on my Google I/O slides and
I realized I wanted brackets to be able to
bump up the font size so that the audience
could see the code while I was demoing it,
but it didn't have that feature.
It's still very, very early.
I should point out this is still very early
stages of development.
So I emailed the product manager, Adam Leeman.
I said, "Can you guys add this by Google I/O?"
Or I said, "Are you planning on adding this
by Google I/O?"
And he responds, he says, "Here's the link,"
you know, "here's a link to the public -- public
backlog, you can check for yourself, it's
all public, you don't have to ask me."
And actually he didn't say it like that because
he's a nice guy.
But I went and I looked and it wasn't scheduled.
I said, "Well, can you guys get it in?"
He said, "No, but it's open source you can
get in."
I thought, you know, that's true.
Like that -- like, I'm really critical of
editors, right?
We all are.
Everyone in this room is really critical about
editors.
And for the first time I just had the power
to make it how I wanted it.
So I just forked it, I mean, I'm a good JavaScript
programmer, I forked it, you know, I cloned
it, I branched it, and I built the feature
all in JavaScript and submitted a report request
and it got merged and I added the feature.
It was really empowering to be able to just
change things I didn't like about the editor
that I use every day.
I'm sorry, I forgot to change that back.
Thank you.
So brackets is intended to run outside of
the browser for now.
Right?
So we built it with Web technologies, we were
first thinking like wouldn't it be awesome
to take this editor and actually run it inside
of a browser?
We thought that might be really innovative
and cool and different.
Then we thought, no, probably not.
We want to focus on a more traditional development
experience right now and keep it outside of
the browser, but we are definitely looking
at embedding it in the browser in the future
and accessing various cloud serves with it.
We are not trying to build an IDE.
We are trying to build a streamlined editor.
We are not trying to compete with Visual Studio,
Eclipse or something like that.
We are trying to build something fast and
streamlined.
We want it to be an editor.
And so we have a good extension model.
It's an evolving extension model, which is
really designed to help us keep a lot of the
things that maybe everybody doesn't want out
of the core product and so that people can
just bring in what they want.
And the last thing that I want to say is that
the core editor is codemirror, which is a
separate project which is something that we
are also actively contributing to.
Okay.
So enough talk.
Let's take a look at it.
In fact, you actually have already seen it,
so this is brackets.
I was using it earlier.
It's a very simple editor.
I mean, I have my files over here on the left,
I have my code here on the right, and I can
hide my files.
You know, I have some menus up here.
These are actually temporary.
These menus are going to become native menus.
They are just in here temporarily.
But this is it.
I mean it's a relatively straightforward and
simple experience, simple UI.
And the point of brackets is to really sort
of get out of your way.
And it's to sort of break down the barriers
between what it is that you intend to do and
actually doing it.
So if I'm looking at this piece of text right
here and I decide that I want to make some
kind of a change to it, let's say I want to
tweak the line height of this text, then the
first thing that I have to start doing is
dig through a bunch of CSS files, right?
And, you know, I have to look at, you know,
I have to look for selector vision, I have
to look for this ID, I have to look for main
content or maybe article, I have to look for,
you know, maybe a container and I have to
try and find where, you know, which styles
are actually applying to this piece of text.
And if this is a big project, I could have
a dozen CSS files, right?
They could be hundreds of lines long and it
could be a real pain, right?
So as I'm foraging sort of around looking
for these rules, I'm not programming, I'm
not doing what I'm intending to do.
It's affecting my productivity.
So instead what I want to do is I just want
my editor to do that for me.
I want to hit command E, I just want to hit
a keystroke and I want to have my editor do
that for me, right?
I want to have it bring up this editor right
here.
This is an inline editor, and it's telling
me exactly which rules apply to where my cursor
was.
If it's multiple documents, it will show me
the different documents right here on the
right and I can just pick the right one.
And I can go down here and I can make a change,
so maybe I change this to 33 -- now, this
isn't just a few or perspective of my CSS.
This is an actual editor.
You can see I just made a change and now it's
this file is marked as dirty here and here
and I can hit save.
So I have saved it.
I have actually edited the document, the CSS,
inline, directly in context, which is really
nice.
But it's not enough just to be able to edit
the CSS.
We actually need to be able to see what we're
doing and see how it's affecting our document.
So I'm going to go up here and click on this
lightning bolt, move this over to the side,
and look at this, I'm going to bump up the
font size.
It's awesome.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>>Christian Cantrell: Well, thanks!
Thank you.
And then I'm going to put my browser over
here on the left and I'm going to go back
down to this paragraph that I was talking
about before and I'm going to open up this
editor, and go down to the line height, which
is what I intended to do and I'm going to
start tweaking the line height.
You can see that it's changing there on the
left, right?
Let me do something a little more dramatic,
let me really change it.
So while I'm actually changing it, I'm seeing
what I'm doing, right?
Which is going to make my workflow much more
efficient.
Maybe I want to change this margin down here
a little bit.
So while I'm coding I'm actually seeing in
real-time what's going on here and I can just
save it.
Now, you -- you might be accustomed to doing
this kind of thing in -- in something like
the -- like the WebKit devtools, right?
Where you are able to tweak your CSS, but
the problem with that is that you are not
doing that inside of your editor, so you make
all of these changes and there's no way to
capture them back to your source files.
Let me make this full screen, bring my files
out here and bring up my index page.
Now, this also works with JavaScript, too.
So I can scroll down to, you know, some function,
function call here, and drop my -- drop my
cursor next to a function here.
If I don't remember the method signature,
the function signature, I can just hit command
D, it brings up another editor, I can read
the whole function so I know what's going
on.
Hopefully it's documented.
In this case it's not.
But you can see how, you know, how brackets
is really designed to get out of your way,
to break down barriers, to let you do what
you intend to do and, you know, get your features
implemented as quickly and smoothly as possible.
Brackets is available now.
You can start playing with it.
You guys can start adding features, fixing
bugs, et cetera and we'll have the URL at
the end of the presentation if you want to
learn more.
So those are the things that Adobe has going
on around text, around Web development workflow
and some things we have going on around tooling.
We also have a lot more going on that focuses
more on graphics and for that I'm going to
turn it over to Vincent.
[ Applause ]
>>Vincent Hardy: Thanks, Christian.
Yes, I'm going to talk about graphics and
cinematic effects for the Web.
One thing that I want to point out is the
tool that we're using for the presentation
is actually, you know, it's not a keynote
or not a PowerPoint or it's not one of the
presentation tools.
It's actually Chromium.
Slightly tweaked version of Chromium, but
it's a Web browser running full screen and
the whole presentation is written with HTML
with actually a library called (indiscernible)
but all of the slides are put together using
HTML, so we're doing this in part because
it's possible, of course, and also in part
to test out all of the things that we're working
on and the type of new effects that we're
trying to bring to the platform or that are
already available on the platform.
So I'm going to start with an example.
So what you're looking at here is actually
an SVG image embedded into an inline HTML
document, that's something that you can do
today.
It has a drop shadow, which is an SVG filter
applied to it, it's very subtle, so you might
kind of see it around the edges of the logo.
And it has a gray scale filter applied to
it as well.
And when I hover on it, the gray scale filter
gets animated and the -- to restore the colors
and you saw this kind of flag animation happening
on the content.
So this is using all kinds of filter effects,
I will talk about the different kinds of filter
effects that are applied here and how you
write this.
Another thing that's more subtle on this is
the -- is the -- is happening in the interaction
of the SVG MH with the background, you can
see there's a slightly textured background
and the image actually blends in the background
in a way that you have not seen before.
This is not opacity.
This is actually a blind mode.
And we're combining and having interaction
between the logo and the backdrop.
How do we do this traditionally?
So -- oops.
Okay.
All right.
So traditionally, this is done with -- with
authoring tools, so we do this with tools
like Photoshop, we do with tools like Illustrator,
or GIMP, we do this with tools like After
Effects.
Those tools combined let you create better
graphics, that let you define complex vector
effects or filter effects or let you play
with, you know -- you know, measures of coordinates
in a space to do effects like flags.
How do you do this on the Web platform, though?
So this is coming to the Web.
The way it's coming is through a number of
filter effects.
We have -- we have -- at the bottom in gray
we have the text shadow and box shadow, and
I have a glitch in my rendering here.
I apologize for that, but so text shadow and
box shadow are kind of the ancestors of the
modern filter effects that are coming.
They can do simple things, but they are available,
and they can be powerful.
And we have the new filter property, and that
starts to be implemented in -- in the browser
and starts to being -- using the browser.
If you've seen the keynote this morning, the
Cirque du Soleil demo was using filter effects
and they are now in Chromium and WebKit as
well, they are also in IE for -- for scale
or vector graphics.
The way you use filter effects is in one of
three ways.
The -- this is one to start with is probably
filter graphs, those are filter defines as
a set of nodes that you can combine to create
the effect that you would want, very much
like you would do in a tool.
The second way is through shorthands, so filter
shorthands are shorthands for filter graphs.
So there are some filter types that are, you
know, very common that you might want to use.
And instead of repeating the same filter graph
over and over again, the specification provides
the shorthands for those.
And then the third way is custom filters or
shaders, which gives you the full power and
full access to the power of the GPU.
It's a new proposal.
It's being standardized right now and this
is what does the GPX like the waving effect
that we saw.
So the first -- the few effects about what's
possible today.
This is just playing with text shadow and
combining multiple text shadows of different
colors.
You can do a neon-like effect and when I hover
on it, I get a nicer glow.
It's very simple, and it's just combining
CSS animation and the filter property.
The tech shadow property, sorry.
Similarly you can use a box shadow, so the
box shadow will apply, (inaudible) of tech
shadow, but to the box, the CSS box, and we
can use it for example, to track the user's
attention on, you know, where the text entry
currently is, so here I have, you know, laser
saber effect on the text entry, and that helps
the user, that helps the usability, and so
it's pretty pleasant visually.
So these are available today and people start
using those on Web pages.
Now, let's turn to the new filter effects
and the ones that are starting to be available
now.
The -- the easiest way to use them is with
shorthands, so if you'll look at the way you
would write this in your CSS, you would just
add the filter property, you would say colon,
and then you'll invoke one of the filter functions,
so if we do this on this original image, and
apply, for example, a gray scale filter, I
just have to say, you know, filter, Colin,
gray scale one, and that applies a full gray
scale filter, and one of the beauties of this
is that I can vary the parameter in the gray
scale function and that can be subjected to
CSS animations and CSS transitions making
it extremely trivial to write, say, hover
effect where, you know, the image will go
from gray scale to full color on hover.
There's a bunch of those effects, not going
to go through all of them, but you can see
that visually they provide, you know, already
a pretty nice variety of things you can do.
Now, the -- oops.
Having problems with my navigation.
Sorry about this.
As I said earlier, the shorthand filters are
actually shorthands for filter graphs, and
filter graphs come from SVG.
They are now being applied to not just SVG
element, but all of HTML, and I'm going to
show you something that traditionally you
would do in Photoshop, remember, you know,
many years ago I used to read those books
called Photoshop Wow! books, and there was
one edition for each version of Photoshop,
and they would explain how to do those, you
know, the combination of filter effects to
do something like a chiseled gold effect,
and the way you would put this on your Web
page is you would do it in Photoshop, you'd
do export this as a PNG or a JPEG and then
insert that into your Web page.
Well, now, you can design your filter, but
you don't have to, you know, export as a PNG,
it can still be text, so here I'm going to
filter a piece of text, which means that my
content remains searchable, et cetera, and
accessible, and I can toggle that, you know,
nice gold chiseled effect.
And also since this is all declarative and
it's done in markup, I can manipulate it -- I
can manipulate it dynamically in JavaScript,
so here I've done something, you know, fairly
simple.
I hooked up one of the lighting filters in
this filter graph to the position of the mouse,
and as a result, when I move the mouse, the
light seems to come from a different direction,
so that's, you know, pretty nice flexibility.
So, you know, maybe you're not putting, you
know, chiseled gold on your page that often,
but something that's more common is something
like this, curve shadows.
So curve shadow is something you see on a
lot of Web pages today, and the way it's implemented,
right now in the best case, because there
are sometimes horrible hacks, but the case
use before and after elements boxes that are
moved to the side of the box and they're rotated,
and they have a background box shadow on them,
but this is, you know, a little convoluted,
this is really visual effect and belongs to
filters.
That turns out to be fairly simple to write
in -- as a filter graph, and also the nice
thing about it, it's very easy to remain place
for script or CSS, so here I can just manipulate
one of the parameters of one of the nodes
in that filter graph and have varying effects.
So to give you a feel of what this looks like,
here is a little code sample, and the thing
that is important to note here is that I'm
not going to go through all the details of
that filter graph, but things to remember
are you have a filter element, that's the
top element here in the light blue color,
and that's what you would reference from your
filter property, so the filter property will
point to it, and then you have a number of
filter nodes that you can arrange and combine.
They each produce a different effect.
And at the end of the filter you can combine
and arrange those effects and stack them up
in the way you want.
So that's very similar again to what you would
do in an authoring tool, and all those operation
and combinations can be captured in the markup,
and the nice thing again is that since this
is markup, this is part of the DOM, and the
DOM is accessible for scripts, and you can
make it all dynamic.
So now let's move to the last type of shaders.
So since the shaders are used for the filter
function again, except that you're using a
new syntax for the value, instead of having
a shorthand or pointing to your filter graph,
we use a custom function.
Before we dive into this, this is what the
kind of things it does, so here you see when
I hover, I start applying a filter -- custom
filter effect and the two things happening
are first the rendering is distorted, it has
this nice curvy effect applied to it, and
that's what vertex shaders do, so this is
about distorting geometry and moving vertices
around, and the second thing you can notice
is there's a fairly subtle effect -- shading
effect on the rendering, so the original element
that we're filtering is all white, and here
you can see there're shades of gray, and that's
what (inaudible) shaders or pixel shaders
do for you.
The other thing that you mentioned is, you
know, shaders run on the GPU, so this is,
you know, usually very fast.
So the model says the shaders is that -- the
conceptual model, when you use it, you want
to author it or just use it as a shader, is
that think of it as your content being rendered
into an image, and then a mesh of points or
vertices is mapped on to this offscreen rendering,
and what the vertex shader lets you do is
manipulate those -- those mesh points, or
mesh vertices in a 3D space, and that gives
you the ability to do all kinds of, you know,
extremely beautiful distortions in a 3D space.
And that is the end of step 2.
That is what the vertex shader produces.
And then the last step is that you can manipulate
pixel values, so once you've distorted the
geometry all you want, you can then apply
the values on the pixel colors, and more precisely
can produce pixel colors that will be combined
with the rendered content.
So let's look at how to use shaders step by
step, so again, very simple, use a custom
function, and you pass parameters to it.
If we zoom in to what the parameters are,
the only required parameter is the vertex
shader.
This is the only thing that's required, so
if you want to just pass the vertex shader,
that's fine.
There's an optional parameter which is a fragment
shader that will manipulate the pixel values,
then you specify the vertex mesh.
The vertex mesh is the granularity you want
for, you know, how many points you want to
be able to manipulate that will be mapped
on top of your rendering.
Depending on the effect, you may want more
or less of them.
And then finally, and this is very powerful,
you can pass parameters to vertex shaders,
and those parameters can then be animated
through CSS transitions and CSS animations,
sorry.
All right.
So let's look at step by step, if I use only
a vertex shader and the size of the vertex
mesh, here is how it looks, on the left-hand
side is the thing I want to filter.
On top of it I've drawn the vortex mesh or
something that symbolizes the vertex mesh.
This little gray square represents the vertex
mesh, so I've asked for a vertex mesh that
is two rows and two chums, so I have, you
know, nine vertices to manipulate, and now
on the right-hand side you can see that all
of those vertices have been moved -- have
been moved by my vertex shader, and as a result,
I get this distortion that gives the impression
that my element has been folded in two.
Now, what if I wanted to do something a little
more sophisticated and give it a little more
realistic look, like if I wanted the thing
to be darker at the -- you know, where the
fold happens in the center, and just regular
coloring on the edges.
Well, that's when I would use -- start using
a fragment shader, so here I've added this
fragment shader, and what the fragment shader
does is that it looks at the current core
unit of the rendering and will produce a darker
value in the center and a lighter value on
the edges, and this gets combined with the
rendering and provides this very nice shading
effect.
And I mentioned earlier that passing parameter
was -- was a useful feature and a powerful
feature in shaders, so here we have the same
-- the same shaders we had in the previous
example, the one fold, and the vertex shader
and the fragment shader, but I'm now passing
a parameter that controls the amount of folding
I do, and the more I fold, the more -- I mean,
the bigger the amount, the bigger the effect,
and the bigger the shading in the center.
So since this can be, you know, manipulated
through scripts, I have hooked up a little
slider here, and if I go to the left, I'll
have less of the effect, and you see what
-- how the code changes, and if I move to
the right, I'll go to the full extent of the
-- of the effect.
And there's no limit on which parameters you
pass and the type of parameters, the sophistication
offers a wide variety of parameters, you can
pass, you know, matrices, colors, transforms,
all kinds of things which can then be manipulated
through CSS and scripts as well, so it's pretty
powerful things, and this is a simple example
but I'm hoping people will do real crazy things
with the feature.
I want to give a little taste of what the
code looks like.
The syntax and the language that's used for
writing those little programs that will act
on vertices or on pixel values, the language
is GLSL, so it's the same language that is
used in Web GL for when you write shaders
for Web GL.
The vertex shader, at the end of the day,
if you look at line 13, that is what a vertex
shader does.
The main function of the shader, which starts
on line 7, its whole role is to compute a
GL position, and that's basically how you
want to displace the vertex that's being processed,
and it's called once for every vertex.
So if you want to learn more about GLSL, you
know, there are a lot of poll documentation
on the Web for Web GL, but also for open GLES,
because that is the same exact language.
It's -- you know, it's seal like.
It's a little different.
But it's not that hard, and there's lots of
examples to start from.
Fragment shaders or pixel shaders, similarly
it's the same language as for GLSL.
There's a slight difference -- actually not
that slight.
There's a difference with regular fragment
shaders using Web GL or open GLES is the output
of the filter is not a GL frag color.
If you're a graphic expert, you're familiar
with that value, which is the typical role
of a fragment shader.
In our case, and for security reasons, what
we produce is a pixel value that is then combined
with the rendered output.
There has been a lot of work done on making
shaders secure, and the result of this was
that with this modification we don't give
access to the rendered content to shaders,
and as a result they are safe, and they can
still do all the, you know, the use cases
that we've talked about so far.
Now, we don't expect people to, you know,
write as many shaders as they will use shaders.
We expect that, you know, we'll have, for
example, we plan to provide shaders that people
can start experimenting with.
We expect that experts will write nice shaders
with a set of well documented parameters that
a lot of people can use, and one of the things
we've started to think about is, well, how
can we make it easy for people to configure
a shader the way they want and make it look
exactly right?
So this is what the CSS shader studio does,
and I'll show you a few example of that--
of that tool.
So here we're in this prototype tool.
It's not a -- it's not an application or a
tool that, you know, we would sell or anything.
It's a demo tool.
And on the left hand side you have a set of
shaders.
When you select one, you -- the user interface
provides you the parameters that you can configure
for the shader, so those are -- if you remember
the syntax, the parameters you pass at the
end of the custom function.
In the center you see a prototype like rendering
that's affected by the shader, and at the
bottom, there's a time line that lets you
animate the different values for the shader.
So, you know, before the presentation I prepared
one on the -- this warp shelter we have, and
I set it up so that, you know, at time zero
I've set up the, you know, the warp the way
I wanted with this little UI that lets me
move the vertices visually, and the end of
the animation is restored to its state.
Now, if I run it, you know, I will have kind
of a transition effect that -- I may want
to put on my Web page when I'm shoring up
UP's of information, for example.
There's all kinds of different effects you
could do.
Scroll is one of my favorites.
If I go back here, I pre-define it, if I move
the roll ratio, for example, I can do the
effect I want, and again if I run it, it's
going to, you know, show me a preview of this
type of effect I might want.
I can also do things like shuffling tiles
for example.
Here, where -- when I move, I can -- I can
kind of explode the content and that's because
when I move the vertices of the -- you know,
on the vertex mash, I have the option of keeping
them attached in which case it's like moving
a -- distorting a piece of rubber, but I have
also the option of having detached tiles or
detached, you know, tiles on the rendering.
And if I have many of them, I can have a nice
protocol effect like we're seeing here.
So the idea here is to make it, you know,
a visual experience for, like you do when
you're trying to create a grayed-in, except
it's a little more complicated in this case,
and the tool will provide, you know, the nice
syntax that you can just cut and paste into
your CSS page, your CSS file, and if you want
to do the animation effect itself, you can
just grab it here, we export the exact syntax
that we need to go into the CSS file again.
So hopefully that type of, you know, visual
tool will help.
You know, people start using the feature,
and make it painless, and visually interesting
to create them.
So this tool is not yet available, but we're
planning to make it available later this year
so that people can -- can look at it, and
experiment with shaders easily.
All right.
So another effect or visual effect that we're
working on is around texturing and blending.
So blending is something that's very common
in graphic packages, like Photoshop or GIMP.
The idea of texturing is to control how what
you draw blends or mixes with where you draw,
so you draw something, and you want it to
interact with the backdrop.
So currently we have opacity, so if I use
opacity on the menu like this, like at my
"home, about, products" menu, I use opacity
and I kind of see the background behind, and
that's nice, but it makes it a little washed
out, and it's not quite what you want.
It's not quite what graphic designers want,
because they're used to those nice blend modes
that they have in tools like Photoshop again.
We're working on a new proposal -- it's actually
not that new proposal, it's a feature that
has been in SVG for awhile, but it's now being
brought to the larger CSS and HTML, and it's
CSS compositing and blending, and it can do
things like this, so now what I've done is
I've turned on blend mode, it's a (inaudible)
mode, and the blue that I have now interacts
in a different way with the background, and
just to show that this is not just images,
you know, the way people do this kind of effect
today on the Web is that design it in Photoshop,
they export a bunch of images and then they
put it on the -- on the page.
Here I have the CSS animation on the color,
and you can see that the color animation happens
and produces a new rendering for the menu
item, and that gets blended in with the background.
I didn't have to scrub a thousand bit maps
to do so.
Using, you know, blending and compositing
is made with two properties.
It's extremely simple.
I have two small demos.
So what you see here in the backdrop is what
we're drawing on top of, and we're drawing
this yellow bar on top of those three elements.
The way you specify it is very straightforward.
You have an alpha compositing property, and
by default it's source over, so a bit of a
technical term; that just means draw what
I draw on top of the background.
And that's -- you know, so far that's no surprise.
But I have a bunch of options and, you know,
I can say I just want, you know -- sorry.
Destination over, for example, will draw what
I'm drawing behind the backdrop.
I can do source in, dust in.
There's a bunch of different effects that
you can use that will combine in different
ways with the background, so that's the first
of two properties.
The second one is blend mode, so again, if
I'm trying to combine foreground and a background
in various ways, I just use a blend mode property,
and by default it's normal, meaning that the
colors don't interact.
But I can change it to something like plus,
multiply, you know, color dodge or difference
and have various effects, and those are exactly
the ones that you would find in graphic packages
today.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>Vincent Hardy: Thank you.
So, so far we've proposed all this and worked
with the community, the working groups in
(inaudible) to bring this to CSS.
We're working on possibly contributing this
or proposing this for canvas as well, and
we've done a prototype of this I'll show quickly.
It's in -- this is really blending edge prototype
we've done in FireFox, nicely build in FireFox,
and what you see is basically the same concept
in canvas.
At the bottom of the screen here, we have
the -- the code.
I'm drawing two images, and the first one
is the background, which is a visual canvas,
then I change the compositing operation to
be an overlay -- sorry, a multiply mode, blend
mode, and I then draw this kind of colorful
graphics on top of it, and I get this better,
nicer integration with my background, so this
is something that's, you know, again (inaudible)
but we're considering offering this property
for different graphics model than canvas is.
All right, so, the things we talked about
today is that the -- you know, the world of
the Web developers and of creators has been
intersecting, you know, there's been features,
but there's not been that many of them in
the past, and we're trying to increase that
intersection between the two so that there's
a lot more happening on the Web and a lot
more features available to developers, so
this is really the area we're focusing on
now is, you know, trying to make this area
larger and try to provide more tools for this
area, because we believe that if we do this,
we'll have a lot more exclusivity on the platform,
meaning that you can express a lot more in
the markup in your CSS, or your HTML, that
will make everybody more creative, and we
think there's an opportunity for a new generation
of tools and new, you know, new ways of interacting
between creators and developers.
So thank you very much for your attention.
And if you have questions, we are probably
going to be able to take one or two, but we
can also talk after the end of the sessions.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]